Speaker 1: This is really just kind of funny.
It's a comedy of errors. Ronny Jackson, who is
now a Republican congressman from Texas, used to
be Trump's lawyer. He's the I'm sorry, Trump's
doctor. He's the doctor who claimed that Trump
is six feet three inches tall and weighs £239.
Neither is believable. Look at pictures of
Trump next to Obama or Tom Brady. And you'll
very quickly realize that that Dr. Ronny Jackson
went on Fox News and he went back to I don't even
know that this evidence was really there. I'm
not even sure kind of alluding again to the
FBI planted the evidence. Now, the problem is
they've already moved many steps beyond that
deflection. Ronnie, I guess not getting the memo.
Speaker 3: Don't trust the FBI or the DOJ anymore.
I don't trust them any further that I can throw
that entire building. And so this is just their
attempt to try to stave off the special master.
Who knows what they got out of there. I don't
trust these people at all. They came in. They
spent 9 hours in there. They walked in with
backpacks. They kicked out the the president's
lawyers, the Secret Service agents. Who knows?
In my opinion. I'm just going to say, if they.
Told me that they found something I wouldn't know
that they actually found it there or if they
just said they found it there. I don't trust
this organization anymore, the American people.
Speaker 1: It may all be planted. And of course,
the problem is that Donald Trump and others
already moved on and they went to well, the stuff
was there, but it was Trump's right to have it or
the stuff was there. But Trump declassified it or
it was whatever. They moved on from this talking
point weeks ago, and Ronny Jackson seems to be
very, very far behind on that at this point in
time. He he's often a couple weeks behind. And
again, when you remember, he told us Trump was
239 in a63, not a particularly believable guy